aux sables-d'olonne on l'a interrompu ce
soir les recherches pour retrouver les
victimes du naufrage d'hier il n'y a
bien entendu aucun espoir de retrouver
des survivants est le mauvais temps
rendait le travail des plongeurs très
dangereux il se confirme ce soir que
c'est bien la prudence sinon
l'inconscience qui est la cause première
de ce naufrage est maire était dur hier
des vents violents force 8 et des creux
de quatre mètres
la météo et la vie de coup de vent
étaient affichés au bureau du port et
aux affaires maritimes
neuf personnes arrivées au port de
plaisance des sables pour essayer la
nouvelle vedette un geek watch de 8,60
avec un moteur d'une centaine de chevaux
comme celle ci tous heureux de faire un
tour en mer sans même penser au gilet de
sauvetage
le nook bian brise abyan dit-on au sable
les guides de navigation les
instructions nautique et les cartes
signale cet endroit dangereux
de plus pour conduire une telle vedette
il faut un permis mer ces plaisanciers
devait donc connaître les risques qu'ils
couraient en commettant cette imprudence
majeur de dharan se produisit très vite
à peine 1 milles en mer une ou deux
déferlante la vedette coule sous les
yeux d'un touriste à son balcon qui
prévient les pompiers vers 18h15 dans
les dix minutes on était sur place
on a récupéré une victime
on a ramené au port et on a demandé du
renfort parce que cette victime nous
avait dit qu'il y avait six sept
personnes encore dans le fond c'est la
personne qui est actuellement exactement
et on est reparti aussitôt sur place
pour récupérer encore deux autres corps
qui flottait qu'on a ramené au port on
est reparti une troisième fois
on a récupéré un conte a amené et entre
temps il y avait un bateau un chalutier
qui a ramené un corps aussi et on est
reparti une quatrième fois l'an la n'a
plus rien à prouver on avait des
morceaux de bois 2
du bateau qui flattait mais on n'a
absolument rien trouvé on a patrouillé
jusqu'au vers 8h 20h 30
et on n'a plus rien trouvé donc on a
arrêté les recherches pour la nuit
[Musique]